captain lee
below deck is emmy nominated when you
started filming this show almost a
decade ago did you ever think that one
day
that might be part of this experience
the whole experience has been surreal
to say the least
because
i'm like that joe walsh song you know
just an ordinary average guy period but
then here comes this whole amy thing and
it's like wow
and then it just it's just like the
realization of it all just hits you
and you're like oh
have you thought about what a win would
mean that's a tough one i am
very humbled by it
because
i don't think i did anything
to deserve this
so it's just like
okay let's not get carried away guys i
have to let you know
we brought you here under a little bit
of false pretenses someone else is going
to step in to take over the rest of this
interview and that person can reveal
themselves now oh do i feel set up
oh you don't sleep you're good
are you
[Laughter]
i there you probably did not prepare a
speech for this moment you know but
don't worry about it because i'm gonna
ask you questions
i'm gonna
turn my camera off and let kate take
over kate chastain is here people thanks
bryce
what did you say
i said you are going to pay
for what you don't even know yet we
haven't even started the questions
you're going to love it i know i know
i'm preparing you for the winner's
circle at the enemies right
okay
captain lee i trust you obviously
after six years
i would hope so
captain game what do you make of the
show finally becoming emmy nominated
the season that i left do you think
that's like uh driving a boat all the
way across an ocean and pulling it into
dock only for the charter guests to
thank the deckhands
yeah it's
i don't just kidding
i'm just teasing you it's amazing no i
you are definitely part of the reason
that we're where we're at now without
you
uh
no
we wouldn't be here is that why they
sent me my very own report i'd like to
thank you captain lee for this moment
i'd like to thank my family
i'd like to thank the charter guests
i'd like to thank
halo mother i'd like to thank my dog i'd
like to thank
95 of the crew we've had on board thank
you
all right next question
on a scale of one to dolores
how much do you miss working with me oh
on a scale of one to dolores
how does dolores even move no those are
sharks dolores you don't like oh my god
son of a [ __ ] on a scale of one two
finishing a charter season how much do
you miss okay when things are like
really turning
and i'm going like jesus christ where
the hell's kate when i need her i don't
need this crap and if kate was here i
wouldn't have to deal with it it'd be
taken care of you know where i am that's
what i've been
that's what i look for and everybody
that is trying to measure up to you i
will say i saw the trailer the new
season it's very exciting the guests are
on a rampage go [ __ ] yourself i think
it's best we all just no go for yourself
and throw yourself off the boat i love
guest drama because it's not my drama
i am looking forward to the new chiefs
to heather i love her i think she's
fantastic and i think she's gonna be a
superstar here's a little teaser i was
surprised given her job performance
she's actually as young as she is i know
because i would expect that level of
maturity i didn't expect that maturation
level to hit until
she was older than she actually is she
is very mature she is
okay
and she was more than willing to
as you have proven in the past just roll
with it and get it done without bitching
and pissing and moaning and complaining
thank you
um now back to me uh are you surprised
that we've been able to maintain our
friendship on land well hell no
i why what what about that should
surprise anyone i'm just asking the
questions they told me to
okay i'm sorry
no
it's not a surprise to me either we're
gonna be friends forever
absolutely we are and forever is a long
time they i think people that asked that
question why we are such good friends on
land they've clearly never had the kobe
beef chili cheese dogs that marianne
makes because for me that is a huge
benefit to our friendship
they are fantastic and get that stuff
everywhere i'm not going to take the
time to make it but marianne sure does
and she's great
uh so in all seriousness what do you
make of the franchise blowing up in the
way it has over the last few years there
are so many spin-offs so many expansions
i mean we've got mediterranean sailing
australia coming out
uh adventure hard to keep track if you
could pick a new franchise for blue deck
to add to the growing list what would
the next franchise be below deck
mississippi river below deck
fire island ferry
oh one that just pops into my head just
instantly right now
would be uh below deck hamptons yeah
that's a good one i've i've worked i
would be like that would be a facade
that i would love to pierce as somebody
who has worked below deck in the
hamptons and actually that's where
ramona singer invited herself onto the
yacht she didn't stay long i agree it
would be great tv
you're good you're good
what's something you can tell me
about this upcoming season that would
surprise me that would surprise you yeah
no not a damn thing
true trick question
what i think somebody might want to hear
about
yeah
if you thought i was harsh on dolores
let's rewrite that chapter
oh
a charter guest a misbehaving charter
guest a charter guess
more than one
same ground
wow
god damn it i'm gonna rip someone's head
off that's my job now
eddie's back chef rachel's back do you
wish i had warned you a bit about chef
rachel before last season and if so
what about no hell no she's an amazing
chef i did say that i don't think that
any captain should go into a new crew
with preconceived notions or
predispositions to how they're going to
behave
because it inhibits your ability to
think on your feet and to adapt to the
situation as it evolves
and that's what you're getting paid the
big bucks for
whether there's cameras there or not
that's irrelevant you're getting paid
the money to make sure that you make the
guest experience as good as you possibly
can with the material that you have to
work with
well you always seem to do that season
after season and rachel is a great chef
and that's all you needed to know
that's what i wanted
eat my cuter
okay so is there anything different
about season nine from other seasons
we had constraints because of pandemic
that were difficult to work around yeah
it was it was different in the fact that
i guess some of the things that
it would transpire on board normally
wouldn't happen son of a [ __ ] sorry he
will fire me tomorrow me congratulations
on your emmy congratulations on the new
season not my emmy
but thank you for being so generous my
pleasure and i can't wait to see the
rest of the season and please tell
marianne i say hi
i'll do that she's going to be so pissed
if she's out walking oscar right now
oh
i'll come over soon
okay sweetie i am popping back up here
before we sign off to say thank you kate
and lee i hope you're okay with this
surprise
i am totally fine with it i just i loved
it i think it's i think it's great
uh well i am excited for season nine as
well i hope we are not without you for
too long that was the big shock of the
trailer is that you're m.i.a for a bit
i wasn't happy about that i don't think
eddie was either eddie looked like he
maybe had an accident in his pants when
that news came that was a little deer in
the headlight moment already he was just
like
what
[Laughter]
that's on you buddy seriously cap
the whole boat is your ball game now
my life
all right well thank you guys below deck
is back this october
kate is on bravo right now though every
friday night for below deck galley talk
recapping the current season of
mediterranean correct
yes fridays at 8 7 central
[Music]